avise à la population en raison des
récentes chutes de neige le foyer de
fond organise une sortie de ski sur les
pistes d'eau réservé aux enfants aux
jeunes et aux adultes rendez-vous à 14h
près de la fontaine du
village village des Pyrénées centrales
en deux
lettresas des cimes des
montagnes bien protégé dans laallé
on voit sourir un
village le plus aimé des
Pyrénées des
grandouons
duarqué tes montagn on la
couronne d'un Bonom dans
laée si tu viens un beau jour à viens-y
avec nous
tes soucis ne dureront guerre si tu es
parmi
nous comment appelle-t-on les habitants
d'ut Monsieur le Maire c'est une
question qui m'est très difficile de
répondre nous avons essayé de trouver
dans les archives de la commune et même
à l'église on a rien trouvé alors il est
venu un chanoine qui est venu pour faire
des études pour canoniser un ancien cé
alors il m'a dit que si la rivière qui
coule à côté était l'onne comme il été
dit à ce moment-là nous pourrions être
des Onésiens j'ai fait des recherches et
en effet en lame brumère il est dit que
on avait construit un pont pour
enjambber l'Ô alors ce père là m'a dit
alors vous êtes des zésiens et jusqu'à
preuve du
cont à 6 km du lac du mê à 1000 m
d'altitude au-dessus de Luchon ha ne
s'est pas développé comme les villages
environnants à flan de montagne mais sur
un plat là dans une mini cuvette le
charme tranquille des rues bordées de
vieilles maisons de pierre la qualité de
l'accueil de ses habitants all on fait
un récent lauréat au plan national du
concours village que j'aime les 105
habitants ne disposent ni de boulangerie
ni d'épicerie ni de boucherie mais le
village compte deux hôtels restaurants
et un café tabac par contraste avec un
village Galois dont le nom ne comporte
pas moins de 58 lettres
a retenu l'attention de journalistes de
Bretagne et des États-Unis quant au mer
exploitant
agricole il est aussi le seul tailleur
installé dans un village de
montagne le travail de tailleur m'occupe
pas toute l'année et alors comme j'ai
une propriété d'environ 5 hectares je
vais travailler l'agriculture y a-t-il
beaucoup d'exploitation agricole à eau
il doit avoir 22 encore en activité mais
c'est des petites exploitation n'excède
pas à 5 hectares 6 hectares et si on ne
peut pas se moderniser parce que les
exploitations sont trop
[Musique]
petites
en cette saison les travaux de la terre
sont en sommeil oui c'est que les bêtes
sont toutes dans les granges nousons
mangé le fourage que nous avonsmasiné
pendant la période d'été parce que les
bêtes ne peuvent plus sortir à cause du
gel de la
[Musique]
neige
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais il y a aussi surtout on peut pas le
passer sous silence c'est la fête du
cochon la fête du cochon c'est vraiment
une façon de
parler pourer c'est une grande fête
c'est la seule distraction que nous
avons avec la
télévision tous les éleveurs à peu près
t le cochon parce que le cochon élevé à
la ferme que nousevons nousmê n trouve
pas on a en acheter mais ce n
pas cette fête de cochons est pour
nous le moyen de retrouver les amis et
surtout les parents c'est un somme une
fête de
[Musique]
famille et comme un rituel parents et
amis vont à la rivière laver les boyaux
qui recevront la viande pour saucisson
saucisses et
boudin
et ben pour faire le Bouin nous mettons
les fritons l'oignon cuit un peu de noix
de muscade des épices du sel du poivre
et nous ajoutons le sang ensuite nous
mettons dans des boyons et nous le
faisons cuire 7 à 10 minutes dans de
l'eau bouillante et à partir que l' bout
7 10 minutes selon la grosseur du
Boyon pendant que nous faisons le boudin
les hommes jou au CES à la salle à
[Musique]
manger
vous faites des
signes je pour savoir comment il fauter
le jeu alors cette carte si je que
dois-je faire pour l'indiquer à mon
partenairelè des yeux comme ça pour les
autres cartes que fait celui-ci avec
l'œil comme ça cellelà avec la jou
droite et l'autre jaune la celle de d'or
ce qu'on appelle ave l'autre jour et les
trois comme ça les deux souffl et les
les autres les pouon appelle de de de
coupe comme ça c mais si je comprends
bien c'est un jeu de fripon ah oui
[Musique]
fit une
fois untit àlise la plus
grande
[Musique]
le l d'autre fois il avait quatre doigts
et maintenant il en a deux et ça suffit
mais ce qui est plus
appréciable c'est les saucissons la
sauciss c'est le paté et puis ensuite
les jamb qui conservent jusqu'à un an un
an et demi et dans le temps il bon
estomacab il n pasop gros pour une
petite famille ce qu'il faut on doit
faire dans les 13 kg par là
environ faut du temps avant que ce soit
prês la viande trier il faut trier tout
le gras et puis le hacher tout ça ça
prend du temps et le salé et le
salé les jeunes pas beaucoup non celle
qui se marie maintenant font pas faudra
bien qu'ell s'y mettent ell feront comme
nous et l'hiver nous réparons les outils
nous refusons des rateaux des P
ériner le maïs diverses
activités je fais
uneesse que le
[Musique]
ma et on le susp dans les dans les
PES c'est un panier que vous venez de
commencer là Monsieur oui un panier il
est en quelle matière c'est unier
c'était mon père qui m'avait appelé
pour finir les l'Ance et la tresse du
tout il faut qu'on soit de comme on est
pas du
métier c'est des branches de boulot que
l' fait et on va dans le bois fa après
on les on les arrange toute verte et
pour l'année on les prépare et l'année
après on les attache ça ça bouge pas
vous
voyez sens pour la B secour et ensuite
pour balier les granges
et on pas tellement quoi quand même mais
enfin TR qu
par parce qu'ici on a beaucoup d'eau
haut mais on voit plutôt
du ça sert pour attacher les vaches qui
remplace les chînes c'est moins d que
les ches on fait pas crocher les
doigts et c'est un CER de vach vous avez
déjà dégrossi ce travail oui on on part
d'un morceau de bois brut et on le
travaille à la plan qu'est-ce que c'est
comme bois c'est du boulot ou du noyer
et maintenant vous le forcez voil
allez-y je vous
[Applaudissements]
en
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au début de cet an de grâce
Jésus-Christ le seigneur de l'Église
nous fait la grâce de prier ensemble
pour l'unité de son église que nous
avons déchiré certains diront sans doute
que depuis le temps que nous prions
quelque chose aurait dû se
passer certes mais dans notre
incrédulité savonsnous remarquer les
changements intervenus nous sommes
restés ennemis pendant qu siècles en
moins d'un quart de siècle quel
rapprochement pas de manifestation plus
ou moins triomphaliste mais une
[Musique]
retraite bouang vient de qui passent
tous les jours
nous monte deux fois par semaine donc là
le ritaillement est suré également de
boucher alors là là là vous exagérez
vous n'avez pas le temps de faire des
gâteaux et la peur il y a une chose que
j'ai remarqué Monsieur le Maire il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de chiens àut oui je
crois que si on faisait un recensement
il y aurait autant de chien que
d'habitant
peut-être
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'inverse des Onésiens qui peuvent
difficilement mécaniser les travaux
agricoles lesésiennes ne voit plus grâce
au progrès leur main rougir au lavoir
nous avons acheté à la commune des
machines à lav communale et les dames
vont laver à tout rôle et d'ailleurs
cette buande ru est ouverte 24h/ 24 à
leur
[Musique]
disposition
monsieur le facteur oui monsieur vous
venez de quel endroit de lichamp
Monsieur vous montez tous les jours au
village tous les jours tous les jours
alors quel est votre travail ici le
dimanche oh ben je fais fait
pratiquement tout je distribue tout
d'abord le courrier les mandats les
colis lettre recommandé et je prends les
commissions que les gens me donn pour
leur éviter d'aller courir au bureau il
me donnent des mandats des colis et
cetera quoi vous ézarrivé de ne pas
pouvoir assurer cette tournée en raison
du mauvais temps très rarement très
rarement une fois peut-être ou deux en
plusieurs années et s'il n'existe pas de
bureau de poste à haut il n'y a pas non
plus de médecin ça c'est un point le
point noir c'est que nous sommes obligés
de faire venir de Lon et à morte saison
quelque fois il y en a pas beaucoup
d'autres et luuchon est à 8 km au moins
9 heureusement que quand même pour les
urgences nous avons la Samie fort
heureusement les enfants ici débordent
de santé et de vigueur l'école en
accueil 5 sous l'émable férule d'une
toulousaine de 22 ans ce matin nous
allons écrire au correspondants de
Toulouse puisque une équipe de la
télévision est venue à haut nous allons
pouvoir leur raconter et dire ce qu'il
vous ce qu'on a fait fait ce que ils ont
filmé ce que vous avez vu vous avez vu
de nouveaux matériels vous avez vu de
nouvelles personnes et vous allez leur
raconter hein
[Musique]
allez-y à montagne c'est le premier mais
j'ai déjà fait un poste à la campagne à
préserville à côté de Toulouse il
devrait y avoir davantage d'élèves dans
les classes mais ici il y en a que cinq
on ne peut pas les envoy ailleurs il y a
des difficultés de locomotion l'hiver
surtout il y a du verre glace sur la
route enfin ça ça créerait beaucoup trop
de problèmes pour la cantine à midi on
ne peut pas les recevoir dans une autre
école alors on a maintenu le poste
[Musique]
d'eau hier soir ma mémé est allée à la
veillée chez mon mon
cousin on a raconté des histoires et
m'adore à jouer de
[Musique]
l'accordéon
et bien vous voyez il va mieux quand
même ce pour nous c'est plus joli quand
même cette musique que la musique que
nous avons maintenant je le dis toujours
oui
ça et oui ça
nousène après un petit batteur tu
vois toi tu nas pas besoin de bteur tu
as le pied
pour
par on chant oui on chantit on
même même des fois quand on avait pas
l'accordéon on dansait avec des des
bonbonnes des grosses bonbonnes d'huile
qu'il y avait alors jou même qui naurait
pas se jouer mais on était c'est comme
ça on
s'amusait ah oui sont de langue
et
laabî nul est qu'on ne
répond
lointain dans la BR
et voici que la
Lune pas mal est
sor autre autre musique autre
préoccupation un
capitaliste
[Musique]
c'est le problème ici c'est que l'hiver
est trop long trop long jeis pas moi
pour ma part je m'anu pas ici j'ai
toujours quelque chose à faire je
su grand
Magin ce qui manque ici on va t on peut
dire qu'on est rétrograde et il faudrait
créer des petites usines à la montagne
pour retetenir justement les jeunes par
exemple il pourrait y avoir pour la vé
de l'arboue et de la vallé d' une usine
dans un village centre comme Castillon
Saint-Aventin qui pourrait employer
cette petite usine pourrait dépendre par
exemple d'un grande usine de Toulouse
qui vient envoyer des pièces démontables
détachables qu'on monterait ici et qu'on
viendrait les rechercher en rapporter ou
faire peut-être comme vous voyez des
pantalons à ce momentl les jeunes filles
resteraient là et je suis sûr que les
jeunes hommes resteraient aussi et vous
pourriez célébrer des mariages justement
et des baptêmes parce que les bapthêmes
et les mariages il y en a pas beaucoup
bonne neige aujourd'hui
la descente là du téliège en profonde
terrible on voyz pas trop le relief ça
quand il neige c'est toujours un peu ça
hein petit BR à côté de la neige qu'on a
connu jusqu'à maintenant ou alors nous
travaillons tous les trois aux
agutes station de sport d'iveroi
elle est à 11 km de de haut nous sommes
tous les deux à travaillés au remonte
pente vous êtes moniteur pendant la
saison d'hiver pendant la saison d'hiver
oui l'été je suis ici à
que faites-vous l'été j'ai une propriété
enfin propriété de montagne je travaille
ici vaches Mau c'est assez différent
mais ça me plaît tous les deux j'aime
bien le ski mais j'aime bien aussi la
vie du village bientôt on va faire du
ski de fois sur la piste qui borde la
[Musique]
rivière
avise à la population en raison des
récentes chutes de neige le foyer de
fond organise une sortie de ski sur les
pistes d'au réservé aux enfants aux
jeunes et aux adultes rendez-vous à 14h
près de la fontaine du village ce foyer
de fond qui a été créé sous lesgit de la
Jeunesse et des Sports a pour but
d'essayer de développer le ski de fond
d'abord auprès des scolaires les élèves
du lycée de Luchon l'école du bois et
également d'essayer de développer le ski
de promenade auprès des adultes à
l'heure actuelle c'est un besoin car
beaucoup de clients demandent à quitter
un tout petit peu les pistes trop
fréquenté pour s'adonner à un are genre
de ski qui est un ski un peu plus
sportif peut-être qui fait davantage
appel au moyen physique de des personnes
dans notre foyer de fond nous faisons
venir les élèves de l'école primaire de
haut
et ce sont donc des enfants qui ont à
peine 8 à 9 ans et en prenant certaines
préc
SK et la
dernière
[Musique]
voil pratiquement depuis 1915 j'ai
commencé les premiers pas avec des
cercles de bar nous commencions à côté
de la maison côté chez moi et ensuite
j'ai fait priè compétition en
et bien mon Dieu les dames viennent
également et toutes les motivations sont
bonnes puisque certaines d'entre elles
viennent pour perdre quelques kil
pourquoi pas après
tout alors actuelle nous avons de piste
une d d'entraînement qui n'est pas très
longue elle est en terrain facile sur un
petit plateau proximité du village et
elle fait à peine 1 km de long et une
piste un tout petit peu plus longue que
nous avons appelé piste de promenade qui
fait environ 4
[Musique]
km il nous quand on faisait une partie
de boule de neige dans la cour de
l'école gross bise Sylvie cross bise
jeaner grosse bise
Jean-Bernard grosse bise
Simone grosse bise
[Musique]
Philippa y